first joining us more with uh on
tonight's top story senator tom cotton
is with us senator good to have you i
want to go to your comments in
particular that we just played
and you said you know that letter and
you're referring to the letter about
parents and school boards and domestic
terrorists
um you called his
his directive his performance shameful
and thank god you're not on the supreme
court and you should resign
i sat back and i was grateful you said
it senator because it is a disgrace and
i didn't see him give an answer that
made me feel comfortable that he
understood the severity of what went out
here
no he didn't john and thank goodness
merrick garland is not on the supreme
court because he's revealed himself to
be a far-left ideologue in the job of
attorney general
he sicked the fbi and the national
security division of our department of
justice on parents who simply want to
express their opinions at school boards
can those meetings be contentious and
heated yes but a school board
association accused them of being
domestic terrorists and on that basis
alone he directed the fbi and the
national security division u.s attorneys
across the country to investigate and
potentially prosecute parents because
they're worried about their school
indoctrinating their kids to hate
america or their kids being forced to
wear masks or not being in person in
class or in one particularly egregious
case you had the woke school board and
superintendent in loudoun county
virginia who covered up the rape shawn
the rape of a 15 year old girl by a boy
wearing girl's clothing because they
wanted to pass a transgendered policy
during pride month well i'm not
surprised that her father got a little
heated at that board meeting
by the way as he should now what's
interesting about that is that
uh that supervisor
the guy down the board of supervisors uh
that should know better denied no any
knowledge of it but yet the local police
department acknowledged that it had been
investigating it from the from the first
day isn't that correct
yeah and sean a juvie court judge just
announced that this was in fact a sexual
assault and sean that school board and
superintendent transferred that boy to
another school where he sexually
assaulted another girl all because they
didn't want it to interfere with passing
a transgender policy during pride month
you know sean if there ever is actual
violence or the threats of violence at a
school board i'm very confident that
local police and sheriff's deputies can
handle it maybe merrick garland's
department of justice should be looking
into loudoun county's school board and
superintendent who can't protect young
girls from being raped by boys
pretending to be girls you know and it's
a big issue for parents and we'll see i
guess
we'll know maybe a week from tonight
what happened in virginia because this
is a big issue for parents in all of the
commonwealth of virginia
i was really grateful that you pressed
him and he didn't give a particularly
good answer on anthony fauci and whether
or not he was truthful now we have
anthony fauci's emails we have the 900
pages of documents from the intercept
and now we have the nih letter that came
out do you have any doubt gain of
function
research on coronaviruses at the wuhan
virology lab was funded by tax dollars
and that anthony fauci knew
not at all sean speaking of people who
should resign in disgrace tony fauci
should resign in disgrace he repeatedly
lied to the american people and the
congress saying that his agency did not
fund this risky dangerous research in
china of all places now his agency has
admitted that he has lost all moral
authority to serve in this
administration and to give any kind of
guidance to the american people his next
public appearance shouldn't be at the
congress it should be in the federal
courthouse
when you look at joe biden's overall
presidency from afghanistan to the
border to more people dead in 2021 of
covet inflation the economy energy
foreign policy can you name a single
success senator because i read and watch
every day every detail of what he's
doing and i don't see one area where i
can say wow he's doing a good job here
or here or here i don't see it
uh no sean although i guess he seems to
have generated a lot of enthusiasm at
college uh football games
every saturday given the chance of young
college students all across the country
expressing the opinion that many
americans have of the biden
administration
yeah but no it's been a total shambles
no joe biden's been in washington for 50
years no one thought he was ever up for
the job of president and we've seen that
in spades over the last nine months
senator you there were a few of you that
did a great job today you're one of them
and we appreciate what you did thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else